for our rebellion to succeed
king's landing had to be taken
forcefully
no one was foolish enough to believe
that aerys was going to hand his crown
over peacefully
the mad king's reign needed to end
what tywin lannister's forces did was
unfortunate but it was necessary to
secure the iron throne
and bring peace and justice to the seven
kingdoms
my glorious victory at the trident left
me wounded
but i sent my personal maester to attend
to sir barristan selmy instead his
wounds were more severe
even though sir barristan was a member
of eris's kingsguard and fought on the
opposing
side that man's bravery and loyalty was
something to behold
but this meant my wounds would take
longer to heal and i couldn't ride to
king's landing myself
i sent the one man i trusted over anyone
else in this world ned stark
in my place had i been able to ride
perhaps i could have reached king's
landing
sooner and prevented some of the
violence that occurred
when the lannisters entered the city
still
what lord tywin did was for the greater
good
even what happened to princess elia and
her children
babies oh no theirs was the same
cursed blood that flowed within the mad
king's
veins they were dragon spawn
and couldn't be allowed to survive what
would they grow to be
loyal subjects ned with his
damn northern honor
he and i had our first major fight over
the deaths of the targaryen children
ned called it murder murder
it was war it was
war lord stark demanded that the
lannisters be held responsible for their
crimes
was it a crime to put an end to a family
of lunatics born of incest
i wouldn't and still won't blame tywin
instead i sent ned stark south to finish
off the remaining targaryen loyalists
it was only lyanna stark's death that
reconciled us
ned had lost his sister i had lost my
betrothed
and beloved we shared that sad
bond together ned and i
through it our friendship was made
strong again
the battle of the trident may have been
an important victory for the usurper
but it was the treachery and barbarism
of tywin lannister that sealed the fate
of the targaryen dynasty
my father king aerys had ever been a
friend to the lions of the rock
ares graciously brought tywin to court
making him the youngest hand of the king
in history
he gave him power he gave him respect
he made it possible for tywin to restore
house lannister to glory
ares in taiwan governed side by side for
prosperous years still when the usurper
called his banners in rebellion
tywin lannister ignored his king's pleas
for help
and stayed holed up in his strongholds
of casterly rock
in time my brother prince rhaegar was
dead
the realm was in turmoil and the
usurper's forces were said to be riding
for king's landing
what a glorious sight it must have been
when a force of ten
thousand lannister men showed up at the
gate of the capital
with lord tywin at their head pledging
support to his beleaguered king
ares opened the gates for his old friend
instead lannister and his men proceeded
to plunder and destroy the city that he
had called home for decades
as the capital was ravaged and its
people terrorized
jaime lannister son of lord tywin proved
every bit as treacherous
he killed my father the king at the foot
of the iron throne
the lannisters entered the red keep and
tywin ordered the deaths of the rest of
the royal family
it is said princess rainis was found
cowering under her father's bed
and put to the sword she was only a
child
as for rhaegar's widow elia she was
forced to watch as lannister thugs
dashed her baby son's head against a
wall
before being murdered herself
as i was the heir to my father's throne
i had been spirited away to dragonstone
with my mother
queen rayla who was with child as a
raging summer storm
batted the island fortress and destroyed
the targaryen fleet as it layered anchor
my sister daenerys was born
my mother the queen died giving birth
robert baratheon's victory at the
trident was a turning point in the war
for the iron throne
while it was clear the gods were smiling
on the rebel forces
aerys targaryen still held the red keep
at king's landing
as robert was wounded and unable to ride
it was up to eddard stark to make for
the capital
and force the mad king to give up the
throne
lord stark reached the city gates to
find that tywin lannister
lord of casterly rock had already sacked
the city in robert's name
house lannister had remained neutral up
to this point ignoring
requests for help from both the crown
and the rebels
now that robert's eventual victory was
assured
it seemed lord tywin had finally chosen
the side
lord eddard was horrified by what he saw
when he entered the city
homes looted and burned scores of
innocent citizens killed
disgusted he led his force up visenya's
hill to the red keep
upon entering the throne room he found
king aerys
lying in a pool of blood dead
by the hand of his own sworn king's
guard jaime lannister
who sat brazenly upon the throne
demanding to know the whereabouts of
queen rayla
lord eddard was informed the queen and
her son viserys
have been spirited away to dragonstone
before the lannisters arrived
but other members of the royal family
were not as fortunate
elia martell of dawn who was the wife of
prince rhaegar
had been murdered by sir krigor clegane
on lord tywin's orders so griego and his
man had also butchered rhaegar's young
children
when robert was well enough to reach the
capital lord eddard demanded the
lannisters answer for their heinous
crimes
robert refused and sent him south to
relieve the baratheon stronghold of
storm's end
which was still under siege by forces
loyal to the crown
whatever words passed between the two
old friends and heard only to them
but lord eddard is said to have left
king's landing in anger
later when robert was crowned he
appointed john aaron as hand of the king
lord aaron's first order of business was
to broker a truce with the martells of
dawn
who were outraged by the brutal murder
of princess elia and her children
following the death of lyanna stark who
had been betrothed to robert
house's baratheon and lannister were
joined in marriage
when the new king took tywin lannister's
eldest daughter cersei as his queen
for eddard stark he returned to his
stronghold of winterfell
forever haunted by his sister's death
and the shameful way that robert had
secured his throne
rhaegar targaryen lay dead on the banks
of the trident
his royal army shattered and in retreat
the days of the dragon kings were
clearly numbered
until that moment it would have been
foolish to commit casterly rock to
either the crown
or the rebellion what would our family
have to gain
in supporting a raving madman or in
entering a crusade to put robert
baratheon on the iron throne
but chaos benefits no one
it was time for house lannister to do
what it could to ensure a return of
peace and prosperity to the land
i tywin lannister brought ten thousand
lannister troops to the gates of king's
landing
in order to bring the bloodshed to a
quick and decisive conclusion
king aerys had been sending ravens for
months
begging for my support to end the
uprising
in a way his pleas had been answered
as i had suspected ares opened the city
gates and welcomed
my men our plan was clear
crush aries remaining bannerman and
remove the remnants of the royal family
as quickly and efficiently as possible
any alternative meant years of further
war
and a fragmented seven kingdoms
our means were bloody but the results
speak for themselves
as for aries it is true he met his fate
at the hands of my son
aerys had kept jamie close during the
rebellion thinking himself clever
in keeping my son as a hostage should i
decide to pledge support to the rebel
cause this proved to be his greatest
mistake
for when the time came jaime did his
duty as a lannister
and drove his sword into the mad king's
back
with that robert baratheon's crown was
secured
the new king recognized our role in his
ascension to the throne
just as he recognized how useful the
might and riches of casterly rock would
be
if he wanted to keep it
to that end i offered my daughter cersei
as his queen
had aries not spurned this same offer
years earlier
perhaps things would have worked out
differently
with robert and cersei crowned as king
and queen of the seven kingdoms
it was a new day the dragon was
vanquished
and the seven kingdoms would thereafter
belong to the stag
and the lion